[Applause]
the dr. Phil's story Matt isn't angry or
mad isn't crazy yes you know Mickey
didn't finish off that bottle of bourbon
he might realize there's a hurricane
outside well he's no longer a planet so
who gives a good he's gonna
experiment on Pluto there will be
answers judging by these footprints I
deduce he has feet
[Music]
dr. xxx next on cinema snob the first
porno starring cartoon dogs
it's nice a beverage to politely
collapse yeah we want to kill you but
kill you with kindness it's like the
welcome mat it's deep bam--it's house
you now belong to the Disney Vault the
treat survivors seeking revenge on
mystery Inc the nearsighted ghoul had no
idea this wasn't scooby-doo this summer
Walt Disney's doom 64 the links of
Gwendoline Christie for shadow Mickey's
end to do Mickey has a match Disney was
a smoker so Mickey as a smoker at the
sound of the tone it would be death okay
no I don't have any ones or lips but
take this oh it's the newest reality
show
practical jokes insane
[Music]
you know I get the dog I'm just not for
the life of me understanding the chicken
so this is how chick-fil-a comes up with
their sandwich ideas good dog the dog
where's your junk I splice Ugandan style
[Music]
guess it was pretty funny
seriously you should get that looked at
[Music]
Human Centipede for kids yeah you know I
gotta hand it to him the science seems
pretty legit yeats pop Barker was right
spade and neuter folks H P Lovecraft's
mousetrap it's a scariest game for ages
three to the grave
I thought we had something we just saw
transformers five targets I think
this is what Jehovah's Witnesses wish
they could do at every door Oh II love
have you lost weight
this is actually what Sam Raimi
spider-man 4 was gonna work must have
gotten in the funny bone I have no
brother oka God a family bitches that
very specifically sounds like gluten
shadow being cut in half jesus
tapdancing christ I can't even who does
this
why have six doors in the last episode
Oh another proud volunteer to watch the
emoji movie salon run by Morticia Addams
[Music]
sorry I used to give up joke from Big
Bang Theory that's how you know I'm evil
apparently Mickey's a little dusty in
the groin old apartment he has a lot
[Music]
Bugs Bunny says Merry Christmas your
little mr. Mouse I expect you to
squeak see kids this is what happens
when you eat at Arby's before bedtime
[Music]
hey kids what have we learned today
that a story about a boy and this dog
can be made better with buzzsaws
skeletons and a creepy scientist who
makes the marquis de sade mr. Rogers
[Applause]
[Music]
hello when someone walks in front of a
red curtain it's to tell you that you're
about to see something scary and indeed
by internet standards you will be seeing
something scary tonight opinion
I know sometimes opinions can be scary
especially when they're not your own but
remember when nostalgia critic reviewed
it for the first time and everyone got
really angry and now everyone wants him
to do a Stephen King review once a year
so being the Internet we can all be
adults here and just agree that there's
better things to argue so he wrote me a
little backups
any new baby shitpants got a problem
with that
join up with me
[Applause]
enjoy the review have a good time and
remember if anyone feels triggered you
can say hello
[Music]
[Applause]
so I hear your cinematic version is
breaking all sorts of box-office records
you know when mine was on TV the ratings
were through the roof ratings Sara how
you measured success before Netflix
arrived title was they told us nobody so
that years later nobody will watch
Family Guy what we measure now is
box-office it's only a matter of time
before people say I'm the definitive it
first is worse doesn't YouTube commenter
would tell you they're already looking
back and remembering how awesome I was
I'm telling you bucko I almost got it no
time pass and they'll all remember me I
almost got it I feel like I really
shouldn't be crowd as opposed to I'm
scary your seat I'm funnier we're not
supposed to be funny
hello boys pour me a cupcake
vodka martini deal Mia we are so not
doing that no oh come on what's the big
deal you always ruin it for people yeah
kids used to be afraid of me but now
they just come up to me and go
things were good you were good I don't
know it like that due to the Stephen
King drinking game game comes with a
surgeon general's warning doesn't it you
see this is what he does
he learned scary things by pointing out
their flaws like asking why my head
turning into a doll plot supposed to be
scary forget it you're not gonna ruin
our fun
okay look both of you are trying to
figure out who's the definitive version
doesn't it make sense to have me hear
both sides to figure out which one is
better have me be the one to determine
who almost got it really know what screw
you I'm not talking about the Dark Tower
movie the president of critics said if
Jesus was a movie this would be the
movie the imaginations of film critics
said just stop making movies altogether
nothing will ever top it and the Holy
Church of heavenly criticism said take
me now death I do not fear you because I
have seen it and I know nothing in life
will ever be better going overboard you
may say writing the hype train perhaps I
say no I challenge you nay welcome you
to find one single solitary thing wrong
with my version of it okay this is the
cinematic version of it
[Applause]
control we see a little boy named George
II and the stuttering brother named she
sure is she you always call a shipper
she she even if it's called the SS
Georgie you want to get to the real
problems of this film enough yeah okay
he's excited to test out his paper boat
in the rain but not before he gets what
he needs in the creepy basement yeah I'm
pretty sure you're not gonna kill me off
before the credits end and also
everybody knows that drain sewer scene
so I'm just gonna assume that those are
light bulbs in the drain though coming
across the infamous clown Pennywise hi
Georgie nope wrong to someone that
scary-looking yeah but they were drawn
to him and he's not even scary exactly
you dumb ass anyways people out so much
as he was a legitimately good clown he
was goofy and funny so he could lure
kids into his evil traps this guy
couldn't lure awkward fanart to tumbling
people's fears you don't feed off their
dogs how about this you know we should
just jump to eating him true over time
acquires a group of foul-mouthed friends
known as the token troupe I mean it uses
a lot of the traditional kid grouped
rows but to be fair it was one of the
originators of it so let's give them a
little leeway like when token girl Beth
seems to get along with the token fat
kid bet so you're the new kid on the
block what are you listening to New Kids
on the Block really yeah really
okay it's like the only 80s big crammed
down your throat really okay do you want
that or do you want to do what every
movie about the 80s does now and have
you win this
now get back to your romantic kind of
maybe sort of relationship I guess will
be somewhat attracted to you later maybe
[Music]
the other characters are introduced
early on through Pennywise scares which
is strangest we're supposed to be afraid
for them even though we don't know them
very well yet like Stanley ha I wonder
why a Jewish temple would have a creepy
abstract painting of a woman I wonder if
it's modeled after that woman over there
I guess I'll tell no one about this
I have no jokes for that moment that was
the legitimately scary scene because
some scares are ruined by the film's
inability to go all the way with its
ideas for example a germophobe trope
named Eddie is looking for his
medication
a creepy looking hand grabs it and holds
it up to him
now this is a brilliant setup framing
the hand in the foreground keeping the
creepy person's identity blurred
building up how scary he's gonna look
this is masterful but then when it's
revealed what he looks like isn't scary
enough it's just a really sick looking
guy he's supposed to be a leper of a con
you could have gone more creepy than
this to a germaphobe I guess that's
scary but to us it's not that bad
scares can be lessened in other ways too
the black kitchen opening mic is quickly
shown the grisly remains of a building
that burned down
[Music]
now this would be incredibly disturbing
if the music just shut the hell up
most of the soundtrack is hugely
over-the-top when it's supposed to be
pleasant it crams whimsy into you like
Tinker Bell being shoved up your ass
everyone's supposed to be scary it works
in the softer moments but there aren't
that many softer moments instead it
turns what should be goosebumps creeping
up your spine into jump scares being
bashed into your skull look a scary
soundtrack like any soundtrack is
essential but when it's used too much it
can become like a lap down your throat
what should be coming to you naturally
let's try the scene again except take
the music down a lot and focus more on
the eerie silence and a few well-chosen
sound effects
[Music]
didn't that seem creepier wasn't even
the car driving by more jarring don't
get me wrong some scares work
brilliantly
like the burned headless ghost his
reveal and the way he moves is
chillingly unnerving it's a little silly
we have to show it's still penny wise
I'm the most frightening in cinema you
do you're gonna be a little silly just
embrace it you oddball of denial that's
not true
remember when I scared bland leader trip
IV Billy by scaring him with his dead
brother
I'm Jeff Dunham if he was ever funny
isn't it yeah but it's still a little
funny too but not supposed to be funny
I do really scary when I run up to him
like this
you can sound like a possessed Olaf from
frozen
this is scary oh my god anyway we can
play the Benny Hill music over that oh
my god totally do that
that's that's that's gold you this one
kid in the film I swear is in his long
separate movie and that's rich mostly
because he's like the dorky version of
ash think about it he has all the
one-liners
they saved Ares a town of beaver traps
and it still it doesn't something
something something's your mom he's
super cowardly I don't go in there
except when he's not you see this this
is my back he's somehow the geekiest own
coolest kid in the entire movie the
consistent inconsistency like the adults
not noticing the blood that the kid sees
is more unsettling in this one ooh
somebody here creepy over here
meaning the blood rocking out to a navy
song the upbeat blood cleaning scene
just Rahl whisk in there like a chick
flick while you're at sea you have no
idea what you're doing now all version
on the other hand we may balloon scary
no time to stop now what all the
balloons are red helping them stand out
more and serving as an eerie visual that
was to Donuts for a long time when
someone just sees a single red balloon
they're gonna think of it second there
used to reveal something there's always
something creeping but the balloon
itself is not scary but rather a
build-up to the actual scare we're about
to get thus when we see it we do start
to get frightened now even say the
bullies are a lot better
yeah the ultimate generic Stephen King
who's not only given a bathroom
very quick to grasp but they also make
it clear that his type of bullying is
more psychotic than most other bullying
it isn't just run-of-the-mill they
acknowledge it's pretty messed up
I've been waiting outside the library
for you been you've waited for hours
annoyed come this direction how dare you
point out my cinematic flaws just for
that oh my god why do you think he'll
with this guy
honestly we're hiding behind you the bed
escapes and comes across the loser gang
who attends to his wounds question why
didn't we take him to a hospital I know
that because I read the book but aside
from a couple of a car driving by it's
not made very clear and even that people
are still alive they must have a
somewhat functional medical facility no
time for that Billy sees Bev walking for
the first time it's Lobo
[Music]
didn't he just see her a moment ago in
the drugstore but first time you see
someone like the first time you see your
things slow down
why do it the following moment is it
love that second sight if you don't know
I'm not gonna tell you as a means to say
thanks for saving him
yeah I study disappearances and
histories of towns and they just moved -
wow you're incredibly distinct quirk is
very convenient yeah I guess I'll get
the movie this instead of the FATCA
trope being obsessed with and as he's
obsessed with new kids on the block yes
as I clearly established earlier Wow
still so 80 hey does anyone noticed this
incredibly obvious move me to focus on
that poster while playing a song - I
mean it's right here for everyone to see
I just thought someone would notice it
yeah this comes mostly timeless but
sometimes we got to kick you in the
balls a tease yeah what we get only like
five close-ups of the poster and you
only got two of the creepy clown here
like someone else notice it someone else
notice it did I mention Batman at lethal
weapon are playing at the theater Wow
the eighties are so cool let's never
reference them again
even weirder when Mike appears back in
the movie yeah he disappeared for a long
time didn't he this feels self-defeating
of us fighting our fears silly music and
slo-mo
[Music]
[Applause]
remember when this was a serious
important scene
so they say Mike do you believe in UFOs
astral projections mental telepathy is
movement full trans mediums the Loch
Ness monster and the theory of Atlantis
as long as I'm not marginalized like
that Jewish kid I'll believe anything
you say
you guys forgot I was even a character
didn't you there are so many characters
in this movie anyway somebody was bound
to get less screen time heck I'm not
even here half the time I'm a cardboard
cutout does get genuinely fun again and
that forced fun like kind of like a
neighborhood Halloween haunted house and
the best way it has rooms with creepy
toys cobwebs doors that lead to
over-the-top scares
it's goofy gory fun saying that saying
what things like goofy gory but does
this sound like your voice that'd be
interested in goofy Tori fountain I am
super scary and super serious and this
pretty reimagining of it I contort my
body and turn into all sorts of sharp
things oh you mean with your crappy
digital effects
oh that's just typical of you critics
isn't it I totally forgot he was still
there I know how this works when you
point out that digital effects that
means you hate all digital effects
that's not what I said at all but I get
it you hate Pixar you despise Jurassic
Park you want to see officer Hopps die
digital effects are wonderful and have
come a long way especially in horror
films CGI can make a ghostly image seem
there and not there at the same time
it's one of the few examples where the
uncanny valley actually helps in effect
and half the time it's great in this
film the creepy painting coming to life
the headless boy a good half of the
digital effects are very effective great
that means you love all CGI
I'm glad week
the Sun thing like any effect there's
good and bad ones and when you use them
so often in your movie the bad ones are
gonna be easier to spot the fear of
Pennywise isn't that he's a ghost you
can see through he's supposed to look
like he's really there and if your
digital effects don't have time to
really make it look like his hand is
turning into a werewolf or he's
transforming into a monster because you
have to use that time on other digital
effects the fear is massively diluted
nope it was all amazing and you hate
everything digital like that blurry run
effect how did you do that Oh
[Music]
CGI artists to recreate this fight back
Pennywise showing they can defeat them
so of course let's have this be the
moment where they split up and go their
separate ways
so long everyone it's time we split up
and go our separate ways
oh yeah you really got me there movie
I'm so sure they're never gonna meet up
again no no it's really sad oh yeah what
a shame you'll never get back together
are we leaving we've got him on the run
we should finish him off in those
cliches when they became popular no no
no no no no cliche instead we're going
to put a whole bunch of other ones in
like right well the damsel in distress
for what true love's kiss breaking the
spell wanna go to a chart bar maybe talk
some math let's consult the chart yes
just down there wait what's that on your
arm to cast you to a hospital
I'm new you you're all gonna be going to
the hospital soon oh okay guess I have a
reason for being here now I can tell you
all about my incredibly interesting
backstory Oh actually we're kind of has
a two hour mark we could probably get
you a bonus feature on the blu-ray fair
enough and the sewers were oh Christ
especially when you played this over it
[Music]
but here's something in my version of
the movie that your version never had
people actually floating oh my god
really oh yo that's a really good point
for all the times you always said they
float they always blow we never do see
anybody floating your version but she's
in a hypnotized dance so like mentioned
before man uses true love's kiss to free
[Music]
haha that's so cancer you won't get away
that easily
so Pennywise tries to transform into all
their meals
oh hi kids
[Applause]
well I guess we did it we sure did
[Music]
whoa I'm sorry what are you doing
kissing you oh um I think I have a
better relationship with Ben I mean he
saves me he writes me poetry also I just
did a kissing scene with him yeah hands
off my maybe lady it's the last scene of
the movie are we really gonna end in a
half-assed relationship it's the
greatest thing we ever made as humans
hauntingly hunting the most amazing over
film ever made good super yes good nope
it's perfect and anyone who thinks
different hates movies
well yes movie hater this is a flawless
horror film but at the same time it's
hard to say it's bad too
there's a lot of scares fun ideas decent
enough characters and in many respects
it is better than the original on the
whole I do recommend it as a scary flick
Rondo's Horror Picture Show there is one
thing the original has that the new one
doesn't
what's it personality
the original was silly and awkward but
it kind of relished it from the awkward
effects to the hokey acting to the odd
writing and of course Tim Curry giving a
million percent it's not scary but it's
an over-the-top campy TV movie this is
trying to be an 80s film a timeless film
have subtle scares over-the-top scares
adult humour cartoony humor totally in
stylistic
it's just all over the place I admire if
we're trying so much but they don't
always fit together which helps create
less of an identity so even though the
cinematic version is better
I'll strangely enough probably remember
the original more so yes it is good
enough I just don't think it's the game
changer everybody builds it up to be but
wait you never answered the question
which of us is the definitive funny
which is it well I'm probably not the
best one to answer that but I do know
who is in carnations of the Joker
there's been tons and do you know what
the best ones have in common they're not
Jared Leto yes famous killer clown would
tell you it's best to go out on the
scream wasn't I originally up for your
role why are you really up for his role
yes
you know totally this review with very
confused that's a movie in a nutshell
good point
[Applause]
[Music]
and what is that so it is that what is
that so it is it wasn't anything else
now could it that's it precisely and are
you seeing it with him okay here's the
thing let's not bring John Carpenter to
this that's what it does it drives
people crazy now
[Applause]
you